si queremos obtener una acción o
acciones y al mismo tiempo disminuir su
riesgo de una baja o pérdida para cuando
esto pase podemos apreciar que hay
posibilidad de comprar una acción y
además una opción de venta apropiada así
cuando las acciones vayan por debajo de
algún precio con el apoyo de la opción
de venta se podría obtener algún valor
que apoyara a esto y observando los
diagramas de pago nos podemos dar cuenta
o se puede apreciar que tienen algún
valor que haga la diferencia por otro
lado es el valor de nuestras propiedades
del contrato en alguna fecha futura
interior que desafía la fecha del
vencimiento de las opciones a que voy
con esto a que la ganancia que está
justo aquí es la ganancia en la fecha
del vencimiento y es por eso que se
obtiene un precio actual para poder
entrar al contrato que nos da el derecho
de venta y la pregunta que me gustaría
aclarar en este vídeo es cómo es que
nosotros podríamos obtener el mismo
diagrama de pago sin comprar incluso
acciones u opciones de venta como
podríamos llegar a lo mismo pues con un
poco de creatividad
comprar una opción de compra y una
opción de compra pero esta área que el
diagrama de pago luciera simple pues
nunca seríamos si los precios suben
antes de expiración pero si el precio de
dichas acciones se va por arriba de los
50 dólares la ejerceríamos ejerceríamos
la opción de compra y asia comenzaremos
a tener ganancias pues como el precio se
va por arriba de los 50 dólares y si
este precio fueran de 60 dólares se
ejercerá la opción para comprarla a 50
dólares y así obtener una ganancia de 10
dólares entonces como dijimos que
nuestra gráfica con la pura opción de
compra queda simple para que ésta tenga
un plus y se desplace hacia arriba se va
a componer con un bono y bien el bono lo
que hará es darnos un plus por 50
dólares y como podrás ver esto es un
tanto interesante pues estamos siendo
capaces de obtenerlo por un poco de
menos o casi cero y lo padre del bono es
que se recibe en los 50 dólares en
efectivo a la expiración los 50 dólares
en expiración y ya hablando ahora quién
es todo diagrama lo único que haremos
será representarlo con una línea recta
que es esta que será la garantía de que
se nos pagarán los 50 dólares entonces
al hacerte propietario del bono la
opción de compra termina y debajo de los
50 dólares la opción no tiene ningún
valor así que solo ganas lo del bono y
después por arriba de los 50 dólares
obtendrías lo del bono más el valor que
haya generado la opción y a través del
bono que nos da un plus la opción de
compra con 60 dólares generaría 10
dólares más los 50 dólares del bono por
lo que esta combinación de la opción de
compra y el plus del bono se comportan
igual que el diagrama de la opción de
venta con las acciones así que la
situación de aquí es que si tenemos las
acciones apropiadas con la opción de
venta y su respectivo precio de
ejercicio sea lo mismo que cualquier
diagrama del pago del bono con su plus y
la respectiva opción de compra y bueno
ésta que estoy escribiendo justo aquí es
la famosa llamada ecuación de paridad
que muestra la relación entre todos
estos componentes y de no cumplirse la
igualdad es porque hay posibilidades de
arbitraje que no trataré en este vídeo
pero más adelante llevaré a cabo varias
estrategias de arbitraje con precios
alterados